- On this episode,
superstar Jewel stops by.
(hip hop music)
- [Gary] You ask questions,
and I answer them.
This is The #AskGaryVee Show.
- Hey everybody,
this is Gary Vay-ner-chuk
and this is episode 237
of The #AskGaryVee Show.
And I'm excited, Jewel.
I'm super pumped you've
decided to join the show.
Thank you so much for coming.
Jewel and I met the other day.
We had a great kind of
business chat and hit it off.
She went to the Knicks game.
- Yeah.
- And brought
tremendously bad luck.
That was the worst Knicks game
I've ever been to in my life.
- That was not me.
It happened to be a star player
that didn't show up and
I didn't make him disappear.
- It's true. It's true.
But I was really
excited to do this show.
Obviously, you guys know I've
gone to the call-in format on
this show but I decided for this
we'll bring back
the classic style.
We've got five questions with
Andy over here and before we get
into the questions,--
- Mhmmm.
- Jewel, for the four people
that may not know who you are,
why don't you give a little
context of little bit of your
career and who you are?
- Sure. My name is Jewel.
It's my real name.
These are my real teeth.
Nobody asks me that but I just
thought I'd throw it out there.
I'm from Alaska.
My family were pioneers.
I grew up on a homestead which
means I grew up eating only what
I could kill or can so my
fang came in really handy.
It didn't actually. (laughs)
It taught me resilience,
it taught me grit,
it taught me how to grind.
It taught me self-esteem from
the inside out which is being
able to understand that
you're capable because
you've been given
the opportunity to
struggle which
is a real blessing.
And I ended up moving out at 15.
Ended up homeless at 18.
Was shoplifting--
- Why'd you
originally move out at 15?
- My dad was abusive and so
I decided I would just
live in a cabin by myself.
We'd been pretty transient,
moved around a lot.
Been taking care of myself quite
a long time and so I wanted to
do it on my own without somebody
in the cabin besides myself.
So, too young to drive.
I was hitchhiking in to
work at a pretty young age.
Working multiple jobs.
- Where?
- In Homer, Alaska.
And then I got a scholarship
to an amazing art school in a
roundabout way in Michigan.
Was able to
graduate from high school.
Yay, me.
Most importantly, if I look back
on my life I knew that at 15
I should have been a statistic.
I knew that girls like me, boys
like me even, end up repeating
the cycle that we're raised
by and I didn't want to be a
statistic and so my life's
mission became this idea of
nature versus nurture and
if you received bad nurture
can get to know
your real nature?
And how you re-nurture yourself.
And so my entire
life's work has been that.
My songs have been
a side effect of that.
And my next chapter of my
life will be more about that.
- Yeah, and that next chapter
I think is what
brought us to these two seats.
Obviously, you reached out and
we had a great talk and
I was completely blown away.
Honestly, after you
left I said to the guys,
wow, the
entrepreneurial understanding,
the emotional intelligence.
So much stuff that, you know,
we come from very
different backgrounds.
We have different lives but
there was so much stuff that
you're talking
about that I was like wow.
Like, I get it and I believe
in it and I was really excited
about the meeting.
I think the self-esteem stuff,
the internal emotional strength.
- Mhmmm.
- But what completely blew me
away and why I wanted you on the
show as well is with all the
things like meditation and
emotional intelligence and a lot
of the things that we
clicked on,--
- Yeah.
- I was and I just
want everybody to know,
you know I'm a
tough ass filter on this,
I was really taken aback by
your know how of the market and
consumer behavior and business
savviness and it was really
interesting to me.
- Hmmm.
- Do you ever think of yourself,
do you think of yourself
as an entrepreneur at all?
- Yeah, I think
I've handled my entire
career very entrepreneurially.
When I was homeless, I ended up
homeless for about a year when
I was 18 and I turned
down the advances of my boss.
And when I wouldn't
have sex with him,
he wouldn't give me my paycheck
and so I thought no big deal.
I'll live in my car
for a couple months and
I'll get back on my feet.
But then the car
I was living in got stolen.
And so that's how
I ended up homeless.
And I started
having panic attacks.
I began shoplifting a lot and
I realized I was gonna end up
in jail or dead in short order.
And more importantly when
I was stealing something one day
I caught an image of
myself in the mirror and
I realized I was a statistic.
I didn't beat the odds.
My goal at 15, three
short years later--
- You were there.
- I was there and so
I remembered the saying that
Buddha had said, "Happiness
doesn't depend on who you are or
"what you have.
It depends on what you think."
And so I doubled down on
figuring out
what I was thinking.
And Descartes said, "I think
therefore I am," but if I could
rephrase that just a
little bit I would say,
"I perceive what I
think therefore I am."
If you can perceive you're sad,
you're something other than sad.
If you can
perceive you have anxiety,
you're something other.
We are the observer.
That's an amazing thing.
- Yes.
- And so I began to
develop mindfulness exercises to
help me understand and have
a better relationship with
showing up now.
'Cause fear is a thief and it
takes the past and it projects
it in to the future.
- Sure does.
- And it robs you of the only
opportunity you have to create
change and I needed
to create change or else
I was going to
go down the toilet.
So, I began developing
these mindfulness exercises.
- What did you call them?
Because the term mindful
wasn't really
around then, right?
What did you them?
Do you remember?
- I didn't have a word and I
didn't tell anybody about them.
- Right.
- I just did them.
- How did you know about it?
Had you read something?
What impacted you at that early
of an age to understand to start
my slang term would
be hacking the brain?
Putting yourself
in that mental place,
I'm so, people always ask me
so many things and I'm always
stunned on how
much it's so insular.
- Mhmmm.
- I don't consume other stuff.
I don't know but it was so
there but how did you know that?
- Some of the things
were just very intuitive.
The exercises I came up were
intuitive but I read a had a
teacher that started getting
me Greek philosophy
when I was about 15.
On the cover of my first album,
I have a quote on the
very front of it that says,
"What we call human nature in
actuality is human habit."
I began to look at the idea
that if my brain is addictive,
can it get
addicted to healthy things
instead of negative things?
And studying habit loops and
replacing negative behaviors
with positive ones.
So all these exercises I started
developing for myself were
strictly to get through my day,
to manage my day anxiety.
And they worked.
And at the end of a
year I felt so much happier.
Even though I was homeless.
And so, when record
labels started coming to me,
I knew that--
- Why did they come to you?
Did you have something pop?
Was there anything that sparked
the first batch of
people coming to you?
- I got a gig in a coffee shop.
It was going out of business.
In San Diego at the time, all
of the coffee shops asked you to
pay them to sing
there which was shocking.
I grew up bar
singing with my dad.
- I like these
coffee shop owners.
(group laughter)
Go ahead.
- Yeah.
I grew up singing in
bars with my dad where
we got paid something.
And so I was shocked in Southern
California where they wanted you
to pay them for the honor of
letting people
talk while you sang.
- Right.
- So I found, there's actually
a woman who owned a coffee shop
and I played
there with my friend.
He had a following, I didn't and
at the end I went to settle out
and she goes, "No,
you keep the tip money."
And I was like, "What
are you talking about?
"My friend just
brought in 200 people?"
And she goes,
"You keep the tip money."
I was like,
"Oh, okay, that's fine.
"Why don't I keep all of
your food and coffee sales?
"We'll swap.
It's all good with me."
She looked at my
like I do not like you.
And she's like, "You can
take the tip money or leave."
I said, "You can keep
your frickin' tip money."
And I walked out
and I cursed her.
I didn't cuss but I stuck my
finger in her face and I said,
"You're gonna fail."
I said, "You're stealing from
the people that are bringing"--
- You put her out
of business mentally?
- I put her out
of business mentally.
I am a witch. Yes.
(group laughter)
You heard it here.
- Exposed.
- And end.
Yeah, she was basically stealing
from people and that
no artist would go there.
- Yep.
- So I found a coffee shop that
was going out of business,--
- Okay.
- and I said,
"Before you close your doors,
"give me two weeks and give me
all the door money and you can
"have all the coffee
and sales and food."
And so we struck a deal and I
suddenly had to go out and get a
following and I had to write a
bunch of songs 'cause I grew up
singing cover songs with my dad.
So I wrote and wrote
and wrote handed out flyers,
hustled, I had two people in my
coffee shop that first night.
- Of course.
- And I sang a five hour
set and I sang my heart out.
And what I learned is that I was
very lonely and a lot of people
are lonely and I deserved to be
lonely 'cause I only told truth
in one place and it was in a
notebook that nobody read.
And I decided to take a risk
and be vulnerable and talk about
what was real and not hide from
the truth and so I poured all my
feelings out in
front of these two surfers,
bless their hearts.
(laughs) And--
- By the way,
if you're watching,
either one of these surfers,
please leave a comment.
(group laughter)
Holy shit, I was that dude.
- Yeah. And then the
next week four people came,
and the next week seven.
I played there
every Thursday to try and
have a very regular time.
And then after about
a year, it was sold out.
People were
standing outside the window,
standing in pouring rain for
five hours listening to me
through a window.
- That's cool.
- And a radio station put a
bootleg of mine on the air.
It ended up requested and I got
into the top 10 countdown
on 91 X in San Diego.
It's one of the biggest
stations in the country.
Labels are like who the heck
is this girl on acoustic guitar
playing between
Nirvana and Soundgarden.
They all started showing up.
So it was being Cinderella.
You know,
limousines are showing up.
- Really?
- Yeah.
And so, you'd think I would jump
at the opportunity to have a
record label or a record
deal except that I just found
happiness and I was
not going to give it up.
- Yeah.
- And fame is a path so many
people lose their footing on.
- It's happening to DRock.
He's changing so much.
- He is.
I just watched him right here.
Yeah, he's very condescending
when he stares at me.
(group laughter)
- So you were really
trying to be careful?
- Yeah, and so I had to
ask myself some
very serious questions.
Why am I doing this?
It's very important to know.
If you want to end up somewhere,
you have to know
where you want to end up.
Then you have to have a compass
of knowing how to navigate.
So for me, was it
as an artist or famous?
I knew I wanted to be an artist.
Nothing against
fame, by the way.
It's just which one do you want
as an experience for your life.
I wanted to be an artist.
So everyday I made decisions
based on being an artist not
being famous or rich.
- And that's that.
- And the other kind of
interesting caveat is I was
offered a million dollar signing
bonus and I turned it down.
I had read a book called,
"Everything You Need To Know
About The Music Business"
and I learned
that it was an advance
and that you
owed the advance back.
I knew I was going
to make a folk record
at the height of grunge.
I knew the odds of that working
were incredibly slim and so
I basically bought my own right
to make my own music and
I negotiated the biggest
back-end anybody had
ever been given in
royalties and mechanicals.
- Same thing
I did with Crush It!
- Nice. I love it.
- It's so funny.
- Yeah. Bet on yourself.
- 100%.
- And I grinded.
- If you're good
enough, bet on yourself.
- Yeah.
And I turned down reality TV
shows a lot of shortcut things
but there's no
shortcut to being great.
So I did 600, 700 shows a year
and I did it for years and
I grinded it out and
ended up breaking through.
Yes, I've always liked
myself entrepreneurially.
(group laughter)
To answer your question
in a really roundabout way.
- It's true, it's great.
It's really great.
You know it's funny, I'm sure
these four and a lot of people
watching are smiling 'cause so
much of what I've been talking
about for the last
seven, eight years
has so many of these themes.
- Something I saw on your walls
coming in was about how many
people come to your funeral.
I've actually made all
my decisions in my life,
what I call my
deathbed decisions.
I pretend I'm on my deathbed,
even when I was a young child,
you know, 17, 18 and said,
"Will this matter
to me on my deathbed?
"Is this important?"
- Is this the best feeling for
you as the person that decided
hey, these two people,
do you like are you
finding a lot of gratitude?
Are just like so pumped
in the last 48 hours?
- [Man] I knew the two of you,
and it's rare to find people
like this that care about
living life deeply meaningful,
in a meaningful way.
And when I hear her
talk and I hear you talk,
I love it.
- Yeah, it's one thing have
some philosophical things.
It's another thing to have,
these guys I know, yeah.
It's really cool.
I'm really, really
glad I got to meet you.
- Likewise.
- Andy, let's do
the first question.
- [Andy] Cool.
Carolina asks--
- [Voiceover] Carolina asks,
"Jewel, why do you think so many
people struggle to be happy?"
- Because happiness
is a byproduct,
not an actual destination.
And so people have this
misconception that they're gonna
find happiness like it's Europe
and they're never
gonna move out. (laughs)
Happiness is a
byproduct of certain behaviors
and can set yourself up to win
and you can set
yourself up to be happy.
The sad thing is happiness is a
learned skill and a lot of our
houses don't teach happiness.
That was the situation
I was in and so I actually just
started studying
people that were happy
and I saw what
the algorithm was.
What did they do that's similar
and for me I don't focus on
happiness as much as harmony.
I don't really believe in the
word balance 'cause balance is a
binary thing like oof,
it's a great very tedious.
Harmony is saying my
life has many components.
I'm a woman,
I'm a mom,
I am sexual,
I am spiritual.
I'm a businessperson, all of
those limbs have to have tone
and that brings about harmony.
That brings about satisfaction.
If only have one limb
that is very buff and
the rest of us is atrophied,
we have disharmony,
we have dissatisfaction but
there's no human school and
so that's what I'm
looking at starting.
I want to be able to teach
people emotional and mindfulness
skills so that they can
gain tone in every area.
- From my standpoint, you know
since Jewel took it up here,
I will take into one very narrow
place that I've been really try
to spend a lot of time
on and that's perspective.
It's so interesting to me why
I deem myself happy because
I just am so grateful.
- Mhmmm.
- Like the thing we got excited
about of you know the data
behind being a human
being is 400 trillion to 1.
When you just start there and
you realize forget about the
odds of like beating
homelessness and like other or
like being born in a communist
country like just actually
becoming a human.
I always make the joke that your
mom could have had
another glass of wine.
Or your dad could have
been late because of traffic.
The odds are so insane.
I'm just so grateful for what
I have versus what I don't have
and I think people just have all
these admirations and envy and
all these hard-wiring things.
To me, it's perspective
just like there's always,
I just generally believe there's
always somebody that has it
worse and the problem is that's
where I default into mentally
and have practiced
to put myself there
versus somebody's got it better.
- And the importance
with gratitude is,
I do a gratitude
practice every night,
and when you're grateful,
you can't be angry,
you can't be resentful.
It literally just leaves
no room for anything else.
- I'm just grateful.
Alright, And.
- [Andy] Cool.
Alan asks,--
- Alan.
- [Voiceover] Alan asks,
"How do you feel
"the future of
music is going to be?
"How and where do you
earn most of your money?"
- I'm actually very excited by
the disrupt in the music space.
It's deserved to be disrupted
for really quite a long time.
And this deserved to fail and
I say that with all kindness.
- You mean the people in the
middle having
disproportionate economics?
- Yeah, if I could do
a brief history of music.
Musicians spent a long time
understanding who they were and
what they offered as musicians.
People call that a brand now.
But they were
natural brand creators.
And so Led Zeppelin
stood for something.
You know, loving a
musician was like an ethos.
It was an entire culture and
they were culture builders and
they spent years cultivating
that culture on the road.
Radio came along and it
just super boosted things.
And there's a golden time there
for when that happened and then
radio became so
powerful people realized,
"Hey, I don't have to
have a whole great record.
"I can have one good song," and
then the record labels were like
and we can charge for an entire
record with only one good song
and the consumer
started going,
"Hey, screw you guys.
I'm getting ripped off.
"This is a sucky
record with one good song."
Enter the digital age
and people could say,
"Oh good, I only have
to buy one good song."
- At first, they're like,
"Wait a minute, Napster.
I'm not buying shit."
- Yeah.
(group laughter)
And streaming.
I don't personally feel that
music will be monetizable
in a very foreseeable way.
I think that we should focus
on musicians as brands and
we're lucky enough to use
music as our brand builder,
as our calling card and the
future of the music business is
learning to build
brands around artists.
The artists get
to have equity in.
- Yep. You know, obviously the
monetizing of live event.
So I think access is
where all the magic is
'cause it's the
limited resource.
- Mhmmm.
- Right?
So whether that means
in a show or one on ones
or the brands they touch.
I mean look, it's funny
here you go with the
brand move of the equity thing.
- Mhmmm.
- When you think about the
economics 50 Cent made on just
his sponsorship deal of Vitamin
Water let alone what you're
seeing now where
you're, you know,
celebrities and
musicians are getting
5, 10, 15, 30% of a
business before it launches on
the back of their brand.
It's a very entrepreneurial
answer but it's the truth.
It's a race to the bottom of
control of those economics.
- Yeah.
- Andy?
- [Andy] Cool.
- [Voiceover] Will asks,
"How does Jewel feel about
"social media access when it
comes to celebrity privacy?"
- That's a good one.
- I love it.
I'm in control of it.
I've always really welcomed it.
I've lived my
life with transparency.
I hide nothing.
That said, I always honor--
- We love Jewel.
(group laughter)
You're giving all the answers
that nobody, nobody else says.
Yeah and what's weird is it's
one thing say it that
came and grew from it.
You were real, real
famous when it came along so
it's an even more
impressive answer.
You know, I was a byproduct and
benefited from the transparency
and grew from there.
- Yeah.
- But for you to
be where you were and
love it speaks to
that rare authenticity.
- Well, I also was able, that's
funny I was put in a college
textbook from when
the grassroot marketers,
one of the four founders of
grassroots marketing online.
- Sure.
- It wasn't because of me.
It was my fans.
And it was the early days of the
internet but it was the reason
I broke through grunge.
- But your fans, I was there.
I was doing the
Wine Library thing.
It's why I was so excited.
We talked a little bit
about this the other day.
Your fans got there and
give a crap because of you
and then they took over.
What my fans do now is insane
the level of love but it starts
with I love them first.
- Yeah.
- You have to love them first.
- Yeah, music comes
second in all honesty.
I think people
and what I've been,
it's just been incredible.
I have no middleman.
I get to talk to my fans
directly and tell them who I am.
I don't have a journalist going,
"You know the truth about
Jewel was blah blah blah blah."
And it's not true.
I actually get to
tell people what's true.
I get to have that direct
relationship and not to mention
I should be a gift in, we're all
a gift in each other's lives.
If I'm not a gift
in the life of my fans,
I am not doing my job.
This isn't all about me and so
the way technology is evolved
it's much easier
for me to watch my fans,
see how their
families are doing,
encourage them to be
supporting one another.
I love it.
- Amazing. Andy?
I love it, too.
- [Voiceover] Loca app asks,
"Does social media overall have
"a positive or negative
impact on mental health?"
- That's a good question.
- That's a great question.
- Yeah, it's something
you and I were talking about.
I think that my job as an artist
has always been to look at
culture and look at zeitgeist.
Where is culture
swinging and where do
I authentically
intersect with that?
For me, I'm great at connection
and I love the
technological age.
I love how
accessible information is.
I love that with
education at our fingertips.
I love that it's
disrupting everything.
It have the tremendous ability
to cause a distraction addiction
and we need to be careful with
our children and with ourselves
of how we consume.
Now what does that mean?
It's a very interesting topic.
How do we consume in a way that
doesn't hurt our mental health?
That doesn't cause
neural pathways of addiction and
distraction addiction and
that's actually a
very fascinating topic.
- I think the thing that a lot
of people are talking about,
Simon Sinek has a video that's
going viral on this right now.
I think the question
becomes that we never do is
what was the alternative?
- Mhmmm.
- So, it's one thing to say that
we're addicted to this and we're
spending our time on this.
My question is
that same human being,
what would they have been
doing with this time--
- Mhmmm.
- in 1989?
Would they be
addicted to television?
I had plenty of friends who
played 11 1/2 hours of Nintendo.
- Yep.
- You know we're deploying our
angst against the medium and
we're not looking at
the human being enough.
- Absolutely.
- You know there's a lot of,
there's a lot of kids sitting in
their room on their phone all
day long creating Instagram
accounts and doing
stuff that would've been
on the street doing something bad.
Like this thought that it's all
bad is very fascinating to me.
I don't know.
I am unbelievably
pro-human being.
- Yeah.
- I mean back to just data
and behavior and patterns,
like we're still here.
- Yeah.
- Like we've
had all the ability,
when you think about what we
could be doing to
each other negatively.
We've all, there's so much
carnage that could happen in one
second and we don't and so we
are scared of what we don't know
and I think that,
I think that
I'm surprised by the collective
cynicism of the of
the American market,
for sure, around these
technologies but it makes a lot
of sense to me because
every time there is a massive
communication shift we
are very cynical of it.
- Yeah. And we're frightened.
- We're scared.
- But what I love is the
Millenials already
have the antidote.
So they're already a
product of the culture of being,
having the ability to do this
and look at their screen and
what are they telling us?
We want experiences,
we don't want things.
- Of course.
- That's the antidote.
We get to get out
and have experiences.
- Guys, this is nothing
compared to VR in 20 years.
- Mhmmm.
- People are
gonna sit in their home.
You're never
gonna see them again.
They're gonna put their contact
lenses on and they'll be gone.
This is, I'm being, this is it.
Be happy that they're
actually out and about looking
at the phone 'cause of
the San Diego in a pod and
they're not coming out.
- Right. Yeah.
- Andy?
Really though
because by the way,--
- Yeah?
- to your point, and I
see where you're going.
It's why we've
always loved reading books,
and watching movies.
We need to escape--
- Yeah.
- for our mental health.
- Mhmmm.
- That's what this is.
It becomes the
alternative universe.
The much more extreme version
of that is gonna be the virtual
reality world when they
can absolutely in 20 years
technology put in
contact lenses and be somewhere.
- I always add in caveat--
- Go ahead.
- a lot of people talk
to me about mindfulness and,
you know, about
being in your head.
It's actually not about,
we do need an escape.
- Yes.
- Our minds will
run us, they hijack us.
- Yeah. Yep.
- And so a lot of us use
escape so that we don't,
so that we can escape our minds.
I look at our bodies
as an amazing machine.
And it's an amazing machine,
our brain is
actually not the driver,
it's the steering wheel.
So who's the driver?
I think it's our observer.
When we get so
caught up in our mind
we're desperate for an escape.
For me that's when mindfulness
tools come into play with
how we interface
with everything.
You have to give yourself a
break from your mind that's
healthy habit and not
just constantly a distraction.
- Jewel, just because
you're so deep in this.
This is what I want
to ask you for me.
I'm being selfish now.
I don't know the answer.
I'm curious for
your perspective.
I don't need an escape.
- Mhmmm.
- I don't want to escape.
I'm super duper pumped.
- That's good.
- Like I mean it.
Like, I'm even
scared to do meditation,
this is real because I'm so
happy with my mental state that
I don't anything that
rejiggers anything 'cause
I never need an
escape from anything.
I'm super it's true, And.
I deal with plenty of stresses
and things of that nature.
I don't know, I like it.
It's fine, it's part
of the, I don't know.
What do you think about that?
- I don't know what
to think about that.
But I know you
can trust yourself.
- Yeah, and?
Have you seen that?
How do you think about that?
It's just interesting to me that
I don't gravitate
towards an escape at all.
- That's awesome.
- I don't want to, I want to
stay in my head all the time.
- Yeah?
- It's cozy.
- Uh-huh.
What's it like in there?
- Fucking awesome.
- Yeah?
(group laughter)
That's good.
- Alright, And.
One more time.
One last one?
- [Andy] One last one.
- [Voiceover] Nandip asks,"What
is one simple thing we can do to
"help stop the stigma
around mental health?"
- Well, that's taking
it into a different place.
Right, mental health issue
versus meditation but that's
where he's asking.
- [Andy] Yeah.
- What do you think about that?
- Well mental health is
a really broad scope so
how would we
define mental health?
We could talk very
narrowly about something,
anxiety.
It's something a lot of people,
it's the number one thing
I hear people talk to me about.
Anxiety and I think that's a
mental health issue and I do
think one of the best antidotes
to anxiety for me when I was
having panic attacks and anxiety
bouts was learning to be mindful
which is just learning
to be present right now.
I did it by following my hands
around in the day and it let me
not worry basically because
I was forced to be present.
And so it was actually a very
profound tool for change for me.
- Can I interrupt
you for one second?
- Yeah, go ahead.
Before we get into guns.
- Yeah.
Before you get into guns, and by
the way I've done an incredible
job not interrupting.
I know all of your
watching, I've crushed it.
Are they commenting?
I've crushed it.
Biting nails.
- Mhmmm.
- Now that frickin',
you know I'm so curious,
do you know anything about,
is you looking at your hands,
is biting nails
something that I'm...
Listen, I've got Jewel.
She knows her shit,
I'm excited here.
Biting nails,
do you think that's a move?
- A move?
- Like the way you did that, am
I so at peace and pumped because
I bite my nails all the time?
Like I'm trying to
figure out what that means.
- Do you bite your
nails all the time?
- Yeah. When I'm
really in an interesting spot.
- Mhmmm.
My guess is that's how you're
handling a type of anxiety and
you're gonna think and you're
gonna figure things out and
that's your way of doing it.
I don't know if you're mindful
while you're doing it or
if it's an absent distraction.
- No, it's
definitely not mindful.
- Yeah.
- I'm just not.
I'm just like, wait,
fuck, I'm eating my hand.
Keep going.
Gun control.
- True to yourself,
so mindfulness would be,
"Oh, I'm eating my nails."
- Yes.
- Get curious about it.
Just observe it.
- Yep.
- That's mindfulness.
- Got it.
- And it takes you from
being hijacked by your brain
to back to being the driver.
- Yeah.
- I'm in control
of my brain, Jewel.
- Yeah?
If you're biting your
nails and you don't know why
I'm not sure that you are.
- Well, I respect that but
that's only a micro one example
on a macro level, anyway.
- Good to know your answer.
- Guns. Guns?
- I think guns are
a mental health issue.
- I do too. In a big way.
- I think it's really
important to focus on.
Learning to calm our anxiety,
learning about mental health
does nothing but help our entire
culture a multitude of ways.
And so, I would encourage
both sides of the aisle to start
looking at
mental health, mindfulness,
mental health solutions
instead of talking about highly
polarizing things
look at the deeper cause.
- [Andy] Do you think there's a
stigma around those solutions?
- I do and I often
have people say like,
"Why do you, how do
you talk about this?
"Isn't it scary?"
And I look at them and go,
"Have you never not
felt anxiety? Jealousy? Fear?
"Am I inventing new emotions
somebody's never come up with?"
No. I don't know why
people don't talk about it.
- I think we've had enormous
progress in the
last half decade.
This was not even
being talked about.
- Yeah.
- Ten years ago this
was (clicks tongue) zero.
- I did a pre-tape interview
for the "Today" show and we were
talking about the movie
that's coming out and she said,
"I looked at your
website," she talked to me
about mindfulness
the entire time.
That would not have
happened to me five years ago,
two years ago.
I was flabbergasted.
- 100%.
- Yes, I said
flabbergasted. Two points.
- (laughs) Tell me
two seconds about this.
When did this come out?
What's the basic theme?
And let's link it up.
- Thank you.
Yeah, this is "Never Broken".
It's my memoirs.
People always asked me how I
went from an abusive background,
to moving out at 15,
to being homeless to being okay.
I didn't have access to therapy.
I didn't have the
funds or resources and
so I figured things out.
And I wrote it because
I want everybody to know
that happiness is for everyone.
It doesn't depend
on the right husband,
the right spouse,
the right house,
the right anything.
You can literally do it when
you're homeless and I wanted
people to know that.
- That's awesome.
- And the website
JewelNeverBroken.com shares very
small, doable mindfulness
tools that you can incorporate.
- Jewel every time
we have a guest they
get to ask the
Vayner Nation a question.
Then we get thousands of
answers in Facebook and YouTube.
- How cool?
- So now putting you on the
spot which 'cause I wasn't,
I was pretty confident
you're not a regular
#AskGaryVee Show watcher,
what question do you have that
you'd like to get answer?
Maybe you get some feedback
or you get some interesting
insights to something
that might be on your mind.
- Yeah, I would love that.
Let me think about it.
My assumption, without
doing a ton of research,
is that everybody
is very interested in
personal empowerment and
entrepreneurially
manifesting their dreams.
Would that be accurate?
- That would.
- So, I guess
I would ask you guys,
I am in the same situation and
the music industry there's a
tremendous shift and
when I talked to most of the
record business about
building equity around myself,
around me ethos and my messaging
most people look at me kind of
like I'm crazy and say,
"Why don't you go on the road?"
So whatever you
guys know about me,
I'd be very curious what you're
entrepreneurial
business ideas are for me.
It'd be fun to learn.
- Awesome.
Thanks Jewel.
- Thank you.
- Thanks for being on the show.
- Yeah, I enjoyed it.
- You keep asking questions,
we'll answering them.
- I am gonna
start talking like him.
(group laughter)
It is awesome.
(hip hop music)